pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici un ami et un frère que je me
présente avait dit à son arrivée
monsieur houphouët boigny président de
la république de côte d'ivoire
paroles que devait confirmer et son
geste de piété devant la tombe du soldat
inconnu et ses entretiens avec le
général de gaulle la visite de monsieur
houphouët boigny à paris devait être le
prétexte à une grande réception à
l'elysée à laquelle assistait le monde
de la politique et de la diplomatie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et également par une soirée de gala à
l'opéra où ils ont pu voir selon les
paroles du général de gaulle outre
l'appareil officielle qui marque toute
la considération de mon pays pour le
vôtre le cortège de nos centimes 1
d'exceptionnel amitié mais la définition
de la république de côte d'ivoire
n'est-elle pas d'être un symbole de la
nouvelle afrique ami de la france au
vatican une autre visite a fait quelques
bruits celle que le roi baudouin et la
reine fabiola accompagné des membres du
gouvernement belge ont fait au pape jean
xxiii
on avait observé que pour cette
circonstance la cérémonie avait été
allégé
portes ouvertes aux suppositions le
souverain pontife devait bientôt
d'ailleurs les confirmé lui-même en
annonçant la future naissance d'un
héritier au trône de belgique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cathédrale d'york qu'il n'avait pas
vu tel mariage princier depuis le 15e
siècle
la reine elizabeth la reine-mère le
prince philippe et la famille royale au
grand complet
ils ont assisté à la cérémonie qui a uni
le duc de kent à la ravissante
catharines worsley lointaine descendante
de cromwell
[Musique]
voici dont celui qui fut l'enfant
terrible de la famille royale
aujourd'hui âgé de 25 ans et capitaine
des royals scotch brite parfaitement
assagi est tout prêt à être bon époux en
attendant d'être bon père
[Musique]
l'élection de miss europe aura été l'un
des pôles d'attraction de la quinzaine
du liban c'est à beyrouth en effet qu'un
jury éclectique utah peser les avantages
de 17 nice européenne qui se disputaient
le titre de miss europe
la blonde isabelle dobson qui défendait
les couleurs de l'angleterre et la brune
yvette de grenon qui défendent est celle
de la france ne manquait sans doute pas
d'arguments
[Musique]
mais c'est l'allemande ina grün mackels
1 m 77 90 cm de tour de poitrine 58 de
tour de taille et 19 printemps qui a
enlevé le titre de mister ans les fusée
de longue portée atlas sont elles aussi
des vedettes en leur genre il leur
arrive en effet d'être capricieuse c'est
ainsi que l'armée de l'air us à vue à sa
tâche van van gogh un million et demi de
dollars disparaître en fumée
les spécialistes américains ont pu se
féliciter d'avoir confié la capsule de
shepard à une fusée redstone plutôt qu'à
une fusée atlas comme il l'avait prévu
initialement
la campagne la bretagne des choux fleurs
des pommes de terre et des artichauts
l'un dernier lui avait fallu faute d'un
prix sinon intéressant du moins possible
jeter des tonnes d'artichaut cette année
elle a bougé pour des pommes de terre
qu'elle est amenée à vendre à perte
il ya donc un problème de la bretagne
mais il va plus loin que la pomme de
terre et l'artichaut
que sait-on de la bretagne pour la
plupart la bretagne est un beau pays un
peu triste un pays de l'un des deux
jeunes est qu'on chantait les romances
populaire le pays des menhirs et des
dolmens cher aux amateurs d'antiquités
celtique un pays de côtes déchiquetées
battu par une mère romantique alors que
dans les peintures des grèves s'élève
une race de chevaux particulièrement
robustes les seuls dit on qui
résistaient à la retraite de russie un
pays a pas de vieilles pierres ou les
remparts des cités et les tour des
châteaux qui raconte des histoires
toujours tragique fond pendant aux
églises qui semble voguer sur les
prairies ou rumine ses vaches blanches
et noires qui ont leur place d'honneur
au palmarès des pauvres de l'imagerie
encore les clochers à jour et les
calvaires aux mille personnages les
pardons l'ebit blues et les coiffes
c'est cela la bretagne pour beaucoup
mais en vérité ce n'est pas cela la
bretagne est un problème national dont
l'artichaut et la pomme de terre ne sont
que des éléments symptomatique
tous ces villages aux noms anker ample
ou en loques se dépeuple 20000 breton
quittent chaque année leurs maisons et
leurs commerces d'un autre âge pourquoi
c'est que la bretagne et d'un
demi-siècle en retard et qu'elle demi
siècle alors que tout a marché à pas de
géant la bretagne a toujours des
chaumières
la moitié des maisons devrait être
reconstruite les deux tiers n'ont pas
l'eau courante
[Musique]
pays spécifiquement agricole les
exploitations victime d'un morcellement
abusif ne sont pas susceptibles d'une
exploitation rationnelle aussi les
machines sont elles rares et la culture
se fait toujours de façon artisanale
comme voici cent ans c'est à dire comme
au moyen-age
si les exploitations moderne secondes
que dire de l'équipement général les
routes sont mauvaises plus mal
entretenue que dans les autres contrées
par des cantonniers aussi archaïque
qu'un puissant
[Musique]
les canaux embourbé leur écluses rouillé
ne semble plus utilisé et chose plus
étonnante encore à notre siècle vitesse
le train n'est de la gare montparnasse à
la gare de brest deux minutes de plus
qu'en 1935
ajoutons que sur le réseau breton la
voie étroite tient tête à la voie
normale avec tout ce que cela comporte
de difficultés et de transbordement
superflu
c'est ont aussi que le charbon se vend
plus cher ici que dans le reste de la
france
alors rien et désespéré sans doute et
nous verrons prochainement les chances
de la bretagne
mais cet écriteau pour l'heure qui pour
at-il intéressé
hippolyte de la belle époque qu'on
retrouvait pour un temps l'âme de leur
jeunesse ils sont 46 cas autant
crachotant qui effectue le rallye
bruxelles/paris madre vitesse imposée 25
kilomètres à l'heure ce qui permet de
musarder chemin faisant et même de
rendre hommage aux pionniers en passant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les routes espagnoles on a parfois
dépassé le 100 à l'heure dans les
descentes pas par imprudence mais parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire autrement
les fera en effet était tous un peu
atteindre rhumatismes madre tout le
monde descend il y a presque autant de
monde sur le parcours pour 24 heures du
mans c'est une renault 19 cents qui a
joué les ferrari de la belle époque en
remportant l'épreuve
mais laissons là souffrir un peu elle en
a bien besoin à son âge
[Musique]
le mans capitale mondiale de
l'automobile pour 24 heures 10 m de
course à pied et en avant pour la grande
randonnée on est tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet les 55 quart temps mais
déjà plaga et ferrari sont venus en
masse sur le circuit alors quoi
d'étonnant à ce qu'elle domine la course
dès les premières heures
est ce qu'il ya de merveilleux c'est que
ce sont deux pilotes de la classe
biberon des frères rodrigues ils sont 19
et 22 ans qui anime les preuves pendant
22 heures
on va croire qu'ils vont gagner
[Musique]
et voici en tête de la brochette des
ferrari c'est entre ces trois voitures
que se joue la première place
soyez maître de votre vitesse un conseil
que ne suivent pas tous les pilotes
il est vrai que la pluie c'est une
tradition au mans ne facilite pas la
tâche des concurrents plusieurs voitures
vont dans le décor les blessés vont s'en
tirer sans trop de mal
après quelques jours d'hôpital adb par
numéro 48 montre le bout de son nez
l'équipement électrique est un élément
essentiel de réussite aux 24 heures du
mans personne ne l'a oublié
on ne peut pas tourner 24 heures se
ravitailler ce qui n'a pas empêché
certains pilotes à prévoyant ginter et
von trips ce de tomber en panne
d'essence c'est vraiment le comble et
pendant ce temps cinq petites voitures
français sur six au départ
ddb par grignote des kilomètres à près
de 150 de moyenne c'est encore plus
extraordinaire que la victoire des
ferrari consécration de la robustesse de
la mécanique de la pl 17 la voiture de
monsieur tout le monde
la victoire de la db par numéro 53 qui
termine première à l' indice de
performance
quant à la ferrari des vainqueurs philly
les gens de bien c'est une même un engin
qui n'est pas à la portée de toutes les
bourses
[Musique]